>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> John Cole: Well, good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of congress.
I'm John Cole, I'm the Director
for the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress, so I'm
the lucky person who gets to have
as his major job promoting books and
reading and literacy in libraries.
And it's a program that was actually
created by a history group here.
It was created by Daniel
Borschton [phonetic]
when he was Librarian
of congress in 1977.
And the idea of was the Library of
Congress needed an office dealing
with the public to help promote
books and reading and especially
to reassure people that books
and reading were important.
In the face of the new
technology of the time.
And if you think back to
1977 that new technology
which Dr. Borschton
viewed is something
that needed combatting
was television.
And in the very beginning our
major reading programs were related
to connecting television
and making use of television
and of subsequently
all new technologies.
To promote books and reading
to which we have added literacy
and libraries as the
years have gone by.
And also we have been able
to through this program,
this noon time lecture program
stress of, the encouraging
of the historical study of books and
reading and literacy in libraries.
The Center for the Book quickly
also has national networks,
we have affiliates in each
state that help us at the state
and local level promote
books and reading.
And we have reading promotion
partners, nonprofit organizations.
We ourselves are a
public, private partnership
with our programs including
the National Book Festival,
which is a major project,
not just for us
but for the Library of Congress.
Is an example of a program
that requires private funding
but we also -- is administered by
the Center for the Book and others.
This has been the pattern
actually for our growth,
the Center for the Book in recent
years has expanded and are able
to work now with a new part of
the library that promotes reading.
Reading Administrators of the
Young Reader's Center which is
in the Young Reading
Jefferson Building.
And also now re-administer
the libraries poetry
and literature program which
includes the Poet Laureate
which is a major Library
of Congress activity.
That we're able to look at
this ins a central sort of way
to see what is needed
for outreach in this area
on the part of the library.
Thank you for coming to Books and
Beyond, it's a special program
that we started in
1997 to mark books
that have been recently
published books that had some kind
of special connection with
the Library of Congress.
And today is an example of a book
that depended in part on the Library
of Congress but on other
research libraries as well.
But we have found that
by having this program
which today is cosponsored with the
European Division, that we are able
to help advertise the
Library and it's collections.
Because these programs are
all filmed for the Library
of Congress' website and
are by themselves a kind
of a standing example of the
value of libraries in some ways
and the way that the Library
of Congress is trying to reach
out to talk about our collections.
And to let people know the value
of our collections and the fact
that in fact the Library of Congress
is a major research institution
that we feel doesn't
quite get the publicity
in many circles that
we want it to have.
So the other part of the
outreach is working hard
to show off our wonderful
Jefferson building,
which by itself is a
historical monument and to work
with the library in a
[inaudible] program now for tours
of the Jefferson building
which is a,
by itself really a monument
to books and reading.
It opened in 1897 and it's
filled with names of authors
and aspiring Americans
and a great show
of American cultural nationalism.
We will have -- we'll hear
from our speaker Janet
and then we'll have a chance
for questions and answers.
Because I would like you to remember
to turn off all things electronic
since we're being filmed.
And a chance to purchase the
book and to get it signed
when the program is over.
I also have a couple of handouts
on the back table for you,
one is the latest, second to the
latest Library of Congress magazine.
We now have a magazine that appears
six times a year and we got out just
in time for this year's National
Book Festival in September
and it's dedicated to the joy of
reading but it does talk a lot
about Center for the
Book activities.
Then I cannot resist also
handing out one of our products,
our latest publication which is
an announcement about the Library
of Congress literacy awards which is
a project funded by David Rubinstein
who also is the generous
donor to half of the cost
of the National Book
Festival each year.
But were able to give awards to
organizations around the country
and to honor them for the work
that they're doing in literacy
and this is a five year program
for the Center for the Book
and for the Library of Congress.
But back to today it's my
pleasure to introduce Grant Harris
who is representing our
cosponsor, the European Division.
And Grant is the head of
the European reading room
and he will introduce our
speaker and get us started.
Let's give Grant a hand.
Thank you, Grant.
[ Applause ]
[ Background noise ]
>> Grant Harris: Well,
thank you John.
I get to work in that Jefferson
building that John Cole described,
he's actually authored a great
work about the Jefferson building.
But I actually get to work there
every day and John you're stuck
over here in the Madison building
I believe most of the time.
>> John Cole: That's
enough Grant on that.
>> Grant Harris: All right,
I am honored to introduce
Dr. Janet Polasky
who has authored the book
we'll be talking about today,
Revolutions Without Borders:
The Call to Liberty
in the Atlantic World.
Dr. Polasky's title if I can
embarrass her giving the full title
is Presidential Professor,
History Department,
University of New Hampshire.
Her earlier monographs published
by university presses look largely
at revolution and reform
in Belgium but also
at 19th century labor
reform in England.
Today Professor Polasky will
talk about her new book,
Revolutions Without
Borders which is published
by the prestigious Yale University
Press for it she conducted much
of her research here at
the Library of Congress.
And especially in the
manuscript divisions collections.
This book has received praise
by critics, high praise.
The New York Review
of Books says this,
Revolutions Without Borders does
three things and does them well.
It identifies and traces
the fortunes
of the most zealous promoters
of the universal cry of liberty
in the tumultuous 28
years after 1776.
It demonstrates the importance
of understanding the failures,
the dead ends, the
unrealized dreams,
as well as the successes
of past eras.
And it contributes to our knowledge
of Atlantic history, a solid
and imaginative work of scholarship.
The Economists magazine says this,
instead of telling the
usual heroic national story,
she ranges wherever her wayfaring
revolutionaries take her.
To Paris and Washington
but also to Poland,
Sierra Leona and the Caribbean.
Instead of confining herself
to the deeds of valiant men,
she also gives the stage
to women and slaves.
The result is a spectacle
the conveys the thrill
of the enlightenment as well
of the delirium of revolution.
Janet Polasky herself has
written about her book of course
and she says this among
many other things.
To limit our history of the
18th century to the revolutions
that prevailed, the American and
French Revolutions is to forget
that history is replete with
dead ends, movements that surged
and fizzled or were suppressed.
Uninformed we cannot
imagine the rich variety
of revolutionary alternatives
in our own world.
Well, with that I will turn
it over to Professor Polasky,
thank you for being here,
please give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Janet Polasky: Thank you
and you can tell first of all
where I've been already today
because I have my Library
of Congress reading card
in my pocket so I've been
[ Applause ]
coming from the reading room.
So thank you very much and it
is wonderful to have a chance,
let's see if that actually
-- sorry I can rearrange --
to have a chance to thank
the Library of Congress.
Because this is really where I began
my research and I'm back here now.
I've just started my next book
and so where better to begin
than in the main reading room
from which I will then
hopefully branch off to archives
or to the manuscripts
and rare books.
So what I want to talk about
today are the interconnections,
the interconnections
between revolutions.
And the interconnections of today's
global society are inescapable.
So why should we imagine that
the founding fathers dreamed
of freedom in isolation.
The Atlantic world I argue
in my book was never more
tightly interconnected than it was
at the end of the 18th century.
From the Americas to Geneva,
the Guinea coast, the Andes,
revolutions challenged the
rule of tyrannical kings
and of overreaching nobles.
On plantations carved out of the
Caribbean Islands by enslaved labor
and among the slave
holding entrepreneurs
of West Africa the possibility
of insurrections lurked.
Terrifying overseers and
government officials alike.
Rumors course the Atlantic
with the ocean currents,
this as one of my predecessor
wrote was a world in motion.
Today no one would dispute the
obvious fact that ideas travel,
revolutionary ideas above all.
Protestors in a park in Rio de
Janeiro declare quote we are the
social network.
A banner quotes Bertolt
Brecht quote,
nothing should be impossible
to change.
But difficult though it is for
us to imagine an interconnected,
cosmopolitan world before the
invention of the internet.
In fact revolutionary
ideas travelled back
and forth across the Atlantic.
Starting in America and reaching
four continents before 1800.
Two centuries before the Arab Spring
without electronic social media
or even in international
postal system, ideas of liberty
and equality in various
languages inspired philanthropists
transporting freed
slaves to Sierra Leone,
haunted governors of
Caribbean colonies.
Informed novelists
and were proclaimed
by revolutionary armies marching
down the Italian peninsula.
How, well that's where the
Library of Congress, not,
never fear is a fomenter of
these revolutionary currents.
But rather and maybe
more appropriately
as a preserver of the documents.
In the 18th century
documents had legs.
They travelled, words travelled
they were no respecters of borders
and this goes from the
obvious, pamphlets, newspapers,
diplomatic decrees, the
kind of documents that we
as political historians are
accustomed to working with
but also I've argued from
letters, novels and even rumors,
words were invested with
the power of persuasion.
Fortunately for historians we have
a paper trail to follow and for me
as will all of my books in fact it
began at the Library of Congress.
I found letters sent home on
package ships by husbands and lovers
who had been dispatched
on diplomatic missions.
Pamphlets transported
in pockets and annotated
in margins by previous readers.
Newspapers reprinting accounts
of clandestine meetings
in Warsaw and Charleston.
Diaries, some intended for
publication and others not
and rumors that tell us more
than the teller intended.
And these are all at
the center of my book.
Not just the pamphlets, that are
available today to our students
on the internet who say why go to a
library, I can all find it online.
But actually the manuscripts
and rare books
that require visiting
the Library of Congress.
Now most Americans know that
Thomas Paine proclaimed quote,
tis time to part.
Goading the Americans to battle for
what he pictured as quote, the free
and independent states
of America, in July 1776.
The common sense was filled
with uncommonly frank language.
Charging quote, there is
something exceedingly ridiculous
in the composition of a monarchy.
But fewer of my amused students
know that he cast the king as a worm
or William the Conqueror
was in Paine's words,
a French bastard landing
within [inaudible]
and establishing himself King
of England against the consent
of the natives in very plain terms,
a very paltry, rascally original.
Paine who claims there is something
very absurd in supposing a continent
to be perpetually governed
by an island.
But less well known is his line
at the end of common sense,
quote we have it in our power
to begin the world again.
In our modern age when nation
state reign supreme we look
to the 18th century for the
roots of the nation states
that have endured into the present.
For the united States, France and
sometimes in more recently Haiti,
that should probably
be true for the Library
of Congress though that's
an assumption that I want
to question in the next half hour.
If Thomas Paine or his
contemporaries were thinking
within national boundaries, why,
I've asked did they
travel so widely?
What did Paine me by, we have it in
our power to begin the world again?
To answer that I think we need
to look beyond our borders,
even in an age that
founded our nation.
And that's to me at least a
much more compelling story
in what Paine saw as a
wide open rollicking world.
So what I'm arguing is for readers
of revolutionary history
and for our students.
Including my students what we've
done is to reduce the rowdy world
when revolutions seem to
be erupting everywhere
into the tidy American
revolution of the founding fathers.
And that isn't to reduce the sales
of the biographies that are all
down on the shelves of
the bookshop downstairs.
And there is that section
on founding fathers.
Or even all of the books that
aren't downstairs but on the terror
of the French Revolutions.
It's just that I don't think that's
the way the contemporary saw their
world in the decades after
America revolted in 1776.
In our obsession with nation
states of our own world we forget
that no inexorable logic led from
an old regime of fragmented empires
to a set of modern nations
commanding the loyalty
of geographically bound citizens.
A Belgian pamphleteer proclaimed as
his neighbor unfurled patriot flags
over utrecked, [phonetic] quote,
over half of the globe all men utter
but one cry, they share but one
desire, humanity united in action,
after being oppressed for so long
under tyranny rises up with pride
to reclaim a majestic
and powerful liberty.
Now these are the pamphlets that are
in the American imprint collection
in rare books along with
then the American responses
such as James Chalmers, Plain Truth.
Which are in the Oliver
Walcott pamphlet collection.
As reported in newspapers
and recounted
by entrepreneurial merchants
form the Americas to Geneva,
the Guinea cost and the Andes
revolutionaries challenged the rule
of these tyrannical kings
and over reaching nobles.
The possibility of
insurrection depending
on your perspective either lurked
or loomed on all of these areas.
In plantations in the Caribbean
islands, and novels written
by about Dutch housewives
written actually
by Dutch writers raising their
children on manuals inspired
by John Lock and among
the and in west Africa.
Where these rebellions founded
independent nation states,
that have endured,
we celebrate them.
The others struggles in Sierra
Leone, Guadalupe, Tuscany
and Geneva equally hard fought
have been largely forgotten,
consigned for the most part
to the dust bin of history.
I chanced on this topic as an
undergraduate, not [inaudible] not
in the Library of Congress but in
public records office in London,
now the National Archives
in [inaudible].
But then and this was
back in the 1970's
when they removed the
lightbulbs to save electricity
and what you really
needed to research was one
of those miner's hats with
the light on the front.
I filled out my call slip and
then again it was by hand,
one of those lackey
things we don't do anymore.
So I filled out my call slip
and have terrible handwriting
even though I'm the granddaughter
of someone who taught penmanship.
And so I got back the wrong
folio, well in the time of course
that it would take was raining
so I didn't bother to go outside
and get a cup of tea, so in the
time it took to get the ones
that I really wanted to get.
I thought well I've got this in
front of me, what else am I going
to do for the next hour I might
as well sit down and read it.
And it said chicken farming on it
and I thought oh great this is
going to be real interesting.
And as I started reading
it in the midst
of all this we're letters
form Thomas Paine.
They had been misfiled they
had just been stuck there.
And I was a senior, I was on a study
abroad program working on a paper
on London radicals and what
I discovered in this reading
that I had not expected at all.
Were the connections between Paine
and the barristers he was running
into in London but
also Jacoven's in Paris
and finding connections
with Germany.
And suddenly I discovered all
these interconnections that weren't
in the secondary sources
that I had read leading me
up to write this project.
So I thought about it and
obviously what do you do
when you're an undergraduate,
you running up to the Arch
of the Saint, look what I found.
And so here are the letters and I
think now they're properly filed
and back in my mind what I kept
doing was filing away Paine's
itinerant friends.
And every time I would run into them
over the last more than 30 years,
this sort of would put the note
card aside or now would write it
on a file and kept it away.
So I found them negotiating
with barbary pirates
to find free hostages, distributing
shoes to French armies on behalf
of the English radicals,
spearheading the insurrection
in Saint-Domingue with money
that had been raised in London
and Charleston and
sliding down bedsheets
to escape a hanging in Dublin.
I just kept filing these
away as I wrote other books
but these characters were compelling
and what was really interesting
to me were the connections that they
made from one revolution to another.
Let me just give you -- and so
these are the characters that are
in my book, there is the Tuscan
merchant, Filippo Mazzei,
whose memoirs I found in used
book stall in [inaudible].
My husband does not like travelling
where I can read the language
because that's where you
always find the great books
and you can also always then
make it into the library.
He was Thomas Jefferson's
Virginia neighbor who served
as the Polish king's liaison
in revolutionary Paris.
Or Anna Falconbridge who's the
wife of a British abolitionist
who founded Free Town
in Sierra Leone.
And recounted her encounters
among the Temne people.
And there's Vanson Oget [phonetic]
who was frustrated by the laborious,
equivocating French debates
over slavery and so sailed back
to Saint-Domingue to lead an
insurrection demanding rights
for all people quote,
without regard to race.
He was joined in his insurrection by
veterans of the American Revolution.
These were not founding
fathers, they're not the subjects
of the books on the
shelves in the down stairs.
Instead these were people
who were on the move.
So the revolutionaries that I kept
encountering in the archives men
and women, black and white ignored
borders and what I also found
that their international struggles
for what they called
universal rights.
Or we would called
universal human rights.
Do not fit neatly into
national histories.
So what I began to wonder was as
I was teaching French history,
why do historians divide
this revolutionary period
into self-contained
national stories.
Why do we keep buying and selling
biographies of founding fathers
on this side of the Atlantic,
or grisly accounts of the terror
and it's humane guillotine
on the other.
History doesn't repeat itself
even if Napoleon said it did,
but as I've discovered
historians do.
Especially because our histories
and our documents are organized
or divided is perhaps more
apt into national categories.
With borders more ridged than
those of the revolutionaries
and certainly more divided than
the revolutionaries discovered
at the end of the 18th century.
And again these are
the revolutionary some
of whom we know quite well.
When Thomas Paine handed George
Washington the key to the Bastille
that had been entrusted to him
by the Marquis de Lafayette.
He reminded George Washington,
this is October 1789 that quote,
a share in two revolutions
is living to some purpose.
And this is a theme that
gets repeated over and over.
There's a Dutch writer, Harry
Pop and he asked his wife,
who he left behind, nice man, to
tend to their family business.
He took off and he writes
what could be more enticing
than to join revolutions
that would humble aristocrats
and dethrone kings.
He set off to skies with a hat
and a wig and two false passports
and a sleep sack and he found
his way into four revolutions.
Or there's the English poet,
a lot of these people we
know for other reasons.
Helen Maria Williams and she
arrived in Paris on July 13,
1790 the eve of the first
celebration of the storming
of Bastille and she woke up the
first morning in revolutionary Paris
to witness right out of her
window processions of men
and women assembling
on the Champ de Mars.
Led by Lafayette including not
only peasants from the provinces
but John Paul Jones,
who's house is --
John Paul Jones' house
is right down the street
from where I live in Portsmouth.
Leading an American delegation
but also delegations from Geneva,
from Poland, from Italy, from the
United provinces of the Netherlands,
from Ireland, England and Prussia.
And at the center of course was
Lafayette on his white charger.
The press reported quote, all
national differences vanished.
All prejudices disappeared.
Helen Maria Williams wrote home, how
am I to paint the impetuous feeling
of the immense, that
exalting multitude.
It was man reclaiming
and establishing the
most noble of his rights.
And all it required was a
simple sentiment of humanity,
to become in that moment
a citizen of the world.
And so you find these
statements over and over again,
some we know well,
Anacharsis Cloots for example
who writes the trumpet
announcing the resurrection
of a great people has sounded to
the four corners of the world.
The cries of joy from a chorus
of 25 million free men will awaken
the people's long asleep in slavery.
So my question as I found
these documents was,
so how in the 18th
century do ideas travel?
Again before social media, 50 years
before the barricades of 1848,
before Garrosh dies on the
barricades of Les Mis in 1832.
A century before the socialists
founded the second international.
So, I found the travelers
that I'd encountered,
first of all in meetings,
in conversations,
sometimes aboard ship, hammocks
slung across the back deck
of the appropriately named
ship, the Salseble [phonetic]
with the young John Quincy
and a young diplomat,
Francois Barbe-Marbois who
observed the keel hauling
of a slave aboard a passing corsair.
We find them talking
in cafes and salons,
the English poet Williams conversed
with we know the French
Jacovan Robes Pierre,
the journal chronicler
the Gayard Forrester,
the Venezuelan General Miranda,
the Polish revolutionary Koscuiszko
and others in her Paris apartment.
How do we know that, well sometimes
they leave us their journals
or their memoirs but we also
have the reporting of spies,
intelligence agencies
obviously weren't organized
in the 20th century.
And we have their records as well
including their records of reporting
on other spies who were they
thought were the fomenters
of the revolution, one of whom
ended up finding his way into prison
because there was no way not
to expose the whole expedition.
Or it's fun to read and to figure
out what their interpreting
as the signal John Horne Tooke
sends out all these what turned
out to be dinner invitations.
But let's assemble at 6 PM at.
And then he gives an address and
of course the spies then you see
through those records took this
as the assembly of ne'er do wells
who were going to start the
next revolution in England.
And you can only imagine what they
felt like when they showed up.
We also can find in the pamphlets
and this is why you don't
just find them on line
but go look for them in rare books.
Because in the margins you
find who had read them before
and you find comments as they get
handed from one person to another.
Encounters on the age transformed
readers into revolutionaries,
I suppose that's maybe not
something you want to promote
from the center of the book.
But ideas did travel and
what's important then
in the 18th century
is this is the time
when people took the written word
seriously which is wonderful for all
of us who are historians.
But I came to realize that what
really pulled me in as a historian
and what all of you who work at
the Library of Congress know was
that it was the documents
themselves.
And I think we historians
and it sometimes looks
like what we really are out
to do is it's our conclusions
that the draw us in,
but I think it's not.
I think it's actually the documents.
And it's actually holding the
documents and I came to realize
that John Bowle, who
is a former colleague,
when I started taking students down,
since I'm in New Hampshire
I obviously can't bring them
to the Library of Congress, so I
took a group of seniors to work
in rare books at Harvard.
And they had all been
working on their papers first
of all they were really excited
because the librarian thought
they were graduate students
and then assumed of course they'd
come from a private institution.
I could say no we're the State
University of New Hampshire.
And she was so impressed because
these students had taken a Saturday,
we all found a common
day, we took the bus down,
they had all been doing
all the secondary research
and what they could find of
primary documents online.
But what was so exciting was
watching them actually get the
letters and the journals that
they had been reading about.
And to realize and
they'd come up and say
but I think doesn't this suggest
and then it would be a conclusion
that was completely different
than they had been reading.
And you'd say yeah,
that interpretation Christina
makes a lot of sense.
I couldn't get them out of
the library, the bell rang,
they did not want to leave.
I've taken freshmen down
to work in rare books
at the Boston public library
and so here are students
who have just started
studying French
and they find there's a
great collection of pamphlets
from Saint-Domingue in Boston so
they would find pamphlets in French
and they could read them.
And they would sit there opening
these pamphlets so it's not only.
You know first they get excited
because it's actually a letter
of Thomas Jefferson
that they get to hold.
But they find that here are
the real documents that went
into the writing of history.
And I can tell when
I can take students
to do that, they become historians.
I can take a class where
they all came in as engineers
and business students but a few of
them will overcome the skepticism
of their parents and
become historians.
So, that's what I decided,
it's actually it's my students
that encourage me and that convince
me that the way to write a book was
to write a book organized
around the documents themselves.
And so what I did in terms
of organizing this book is
as I was telling John, the complex
organization that about did me in is
that each chapter looks at how we
read a different kind of document.
So that of course it starts out
with pamphlets and Thomas Paine
but I'm also looking at the novels
written by these Dutch novelists.
Looking at how do we read rumors,
what do we do when we read what some
other historians have called reading
against the grain.
So it's using the documents
themselves,
because I think that's what's
exciting to all of us is
to return and you all know this.
It's to return to those documents,
now not all these documents were,
some of them are obvious but not
all of them are easy to find.
And let me just give
you one example.
From lots of and this is from
lots of examples from emails
that I've sent out that
were generously answered
by archivists and librarians.
Not to mention all the
visits to municipal archives
and national libraries and these --
so these are the letters
of one of my characters.
Not all my characters move, some
were sort of the telegraph poles
that stayed still that
transmitted messages and one
of those is Nancy Shippen [phonetic]
who lived in Philadelphia,
she was the daughter of the
continental army surgeon general.
And she was courted by the
French attache, Louis Otto
and those documents, those
letters are excerpted in.
They were published a century ago
by Ethel Arms who had found a chest
of documents when restoring
the Strafford Hall in Virginia.
And she realized that most of the
correspondence had been classified
by the Shippen's and cataloged
in letter books deposited
in the division of manuscripts at
obviously the Library of Congress.
Which I then read mostly
on microfilm here.
From this correspondence
we learn in great detail,
probably more than ever they wanted
us to know about the courtship
of Louis Otto and Nancy Shippen.
And let me just read you
one quick example of this,
why we love these documents.
So Otto took to walking past the
Shippen's elegant three story red
brick, Georgian house on
Fourth Street every day.
Nancy suggested a rendezvous with
him on the corner of her garden.
But guided by his French
manners and concern
for her reputation he
rejected what he writes
as your contrivance of the corner.
What's interesting to me is
he's complaining all along
of his struggle to
write in English quote,
a language that is not my own.
But he seems to have no difficulty
expressing his sentiments.
He asks Shippen to read
his true feelings quote,
and these are the letters
that are down stairs.
In my eyes, in my whole conduct
or if it is possible
read them in your heart.
He leaves her house
and he rhapsodizes
in what I think is fluent English.
Quote, you image is entirely
present to me, all my thoughts are
so entirely directed
towards you that I see
or feel nothing in
the world but you.
So we have this whole
collection of letters,
and but in the end
Shippen is courted also
by Henry Livingston who's presumably
the most eligible bachelor
in the United States at the time.
He's a military veteran from
a very well connected family,
Nancy chose him, Otto was devastated
and writes saying how could this
possibly happen, I thought you know
that you and your parents had
allowed me to visit you every day
that meant that everything
was going along
and she gets married the next day.
Her father won't even let
him see her because he's sure
that this will turn
Nancy back to Otto.
Well, Nancy and Henry did
not live happily ever after.
Based on her letters home, which
again are downstairs, to her parents
and her brother from her
new home on the Hudson.
Let me just read you a bit of that.
So, there are two years of
disguised references and whispers
and Nancy Shippen Livingston
learned from her mother-in-law
of Livingston's plans to
install his illegitimate children
of whom there were apparently
many, in their household
to be raised alongside
their daughter.
If her husband had known [inaudible]
fit the bill of a stated ruffian
of a Henry Fielding novel,
then it followed in her mind
that she was quote
the virtuous female
in distress, the wronged wife.
Although she ached after her
daughter she ended up going
to her mother and having to leave
her daughter with her mother-in-law.
Nancy Shippen Livingston
was so convinced
that her husband would make her
miserable at home with his taunts
of infidelity that she chose to
endure solitude in Philadelphia.
So again we've got the letters
between Nancy Shippen
and her mother-in-law.
It's really in keeping with the
novels that were in the earlier,
the chapter just before that by
Wollstonecraft and [inaudible].
And Wollstonecraft's novels
are not things you want to read
on rainy days in Brussels,
they were --
And in fact like Nancy Shippen all
the characters end up going crazy
and dying prematurely and that
is indeed what happens to Nancy.
Not so Otto, so I learned
from a chance reference
in some diplomatic papers in
[Foreign language] in Paris
that I was reading for the last
chapter on diplomatic correspondence
that Otto married the
amazingly named daughter
of the famous writer,
St. John de Crevecoeur.
Her name is America Francis de
Crevecoeur, she was known as Fanny.
And Thomas Jefferson was
their principle reference.
Her story is pretty amazing
and you can piece it together
from her father's papers also
at the Library of Congress
which had been exchanged
with [Foreign language]
with some Jefferson documents.
So what we do know is, this is
from de Crevecoeur writing, quote,
cruel death had taken their
mother, the misfortunes
of war had driven their
father to Europe,
the flames of savages had reduced
their paternal house to cinders.
The subsistence that he
had left them was destroyed
and then this Fellows who's
had, the father of two boys
that he rescues came to their aid.
He took them under his roof and
placed them among his own all
because five Americans had escaped
their imprisonment in England.
Four feet of snow had prevented
Crevecoeur's immediate departure
from Boston when he finds out
that that's where daughter is.
But the evening that he arrives the
Crevecoeur family is together again
at the Fellows household in Boston
and Crevecoeur adds for the benefit
of his European readers, quote to
this image of domestic happiness,
he describes them dancing
with violins playing.
To this image he says must we
join those of order of economy,
of cleanliness and of industry,
and that's what all American
households look like.
And he adds, quote, this
happiness was to be found
in almost every American household.
What it contrasts then to this salon
centered society that he described.
So that set me on what turned
out to be a four year long search
because what I wanted
to find was I knew
that Otto then ends up in France.
Right after St. John de
Crevecoeur is over there,
that he ends up in Berlin and that
there are long periods of time
where he's separated from Fanny
but I could find no letters.
They just, she just like
disappears without a trace and so
of course part of the problem is
how do you trace someone who's maybe
America Francis de Crevecoeur,
maybe American Francis de St. John,
maybe America Francis Otto, maybe
Fanny Otto, maybe fanny Otto,
maybe Mrs. Louis Otto, all
of these attempts but --
Louis Otto's papers are very
clearly carefully cataloged,
the diplomatic ones
are preserved in Paris.
So I found various, you know
those tantalizing hints,
for example the family of a Boston
merchant had rescued her as a child
from the snowdrifts and they
had written their memoirs.
It's a funny little book called
Fanny St. John a Romantic Incident
of the American Revolution.
And then in a familiar
story all of those who work
with manuscripts they had
been loaned to a friend,
the letters and gone missing.
Did they ever exist, did
they go missing what happened
to them, we don't know.
But I didn't find them.
We find great nephews who had
papers that he supposedly loaned
to various people writing histories
of the letters from
an American farmer.
I knew they had been written
but nobody could find them.
And the break came in 2009
when Barbara Baer then acting
early American specialist
in the manuscript division
here found notes indicating
that the Crevecoeur papers
had been for sale in 1976.
This was just like I couldn't
believe it, it was like yes.
You know you look for these forever,
but unfortunately they were offered
at such an exorbitant price
that neither the French nor the
Americans, meaning here the Library
of Congress could afford them.
So the letters were
auctioned individually.
And widely dispersed on
the autograph market.
But I have to say that Barbara
Baer was dogged on my behalf
and her notes tracing the
family papers are invaluable.
The Library of Congress is an
amazing resource for those of us
who are doing historical research.
At the end of how to
do historical research,
is what we tell our students not to
do, you know when you get bored one
of those random Google
searches, I did find,
I hit the right combination of
phrases that the French ministry
of foreign affairs had recently
acquired some of the letters.
As soon as I found that I rushed and
wrote my email in all my best French
to say could I please look at them.
And they were moving out of Paris
so they were closed
for a year and a half.
So, I patiently waited for a
year and a half and the last week
of my term in December a year and
a half later in the rain I showed
up at the doors of the [inaudible]
yes I can finally look at them.
I had written that I was coming
of course and they said oh yes,
they were almost warm
in welcoming me.
Here we will take you up
to read the microfilms.
I said the what?
The microfilms and I said no, and
I luckily I could convince them.
That I needed to see how the
letters were put together
and we all have our ploys, right.
To see how they were folded
and so they actually did
then let me see the originals
and work with the originals.
And it really was worth
all of that wait because in
that I could actually see
then who this woman was
and it showed me a lot
about this relationship.
That had gone from America to
France and the couple that was said
to be the model of an
American household in Europe.
First in revolutionary
Paris and then in Berlin.
So I did come to know them and I
think maybe it's one of those things
where it becomes all
that much more important
because you've spent
so long looking for it.
So those are the kind of documents
that are at the center of the book.
And what I've tried to do also
is to talk about how we find
out documents, not
only how we read them.
So it's these documents that reveal
what I can see is an alternative
political spear, so it's not only
that it's crossing borders but it's
that it is not founding fathers.
That is this is the time when we
really need to expand our definition
of what we mean by political
because it's the time
when Miraw [phonetic] talks
about removing of the blindfold.
When everyone does become
involved in discussions of politics
from the people who brought
me there in the first place.
The merchants and the
small tradesmen in London
who had put a penny in the cup after
smoking their pipes after dinner.
And gather to discuss the politics
in London of the French revolution.
And because they crossed borders
these are all also the people
who will call into question what
the compromises that seem so obvious
to founding fathers
who stayed at home.
So it's the ones who call
into question whose ideas sometimes
they seem like Don Quixote's ideas.
And other times now they
seem so common place.
When the Yale graduate Abraham
Bishop returns for example
from France and he's back and
he can't believe when he hears
that under Thomas Jefferson
that we're opposing the freeing
of slaves in Saint-Domingue.
That the U.S. could possibly
be standing against freedom.
And so those are the kind of
documents that I wanted to find.
So my book has been really also
an argument for cosmopolitanism.
It's a challenge to nationalism as
our only modern political story.
And it's arguing against I think the
historians who have a lot at stake
in perpetuating their view
of a revolutionary world
of the founding fathers.
Who are defending claims
of nationalism
and I think these historians
are sometimes as virulent
as saber rattlers on the
stage of foreign policy.
So my argument is that history
restricted then to founding fathers
as was said in the introduction
that that history limits the
way we understand our own world.
That we need to instead study
the history of dead ends,
we need to understand
history of revolutions
that fizzled out because otherwise.
I think we assume that revolutionary
movements against autocratic regimes
of our own day will eventually,
with just a little assistance follow
in the steps of George
Washington or Robes Pierre.
I think then we're baffled by
uncertain outcomes of uprisings
of Tunisia, in Libya, we're
surprised by Egyptians or Syrians
who like the 18th century
revolutionaries
in [inaudible] or Geneva
or Freetown.
Borrowed their ideas of
citizenship from dispirit sources.
Sometimes from their
neighbors often times
from legends of their own past.
So what I'm suggesting is we can't
just look for liberal democracy
in every upheaval from
Romania to Egypt.
Because if we do we will inevitably
be frustrated by what we find.
Revolutionaries who challenge
dictators will not necessarily turn
out to be liberals.
Nor will their struggle follow a
path any of us had expected based
on what we know from our
national history as we tell it.
So as a historian I'm boldly
suggesting that understanding flows
in both directions, from the past
to the present and from the present
to our understanding of the past.
To forget the messiness of
the past is to be condemned
to judge the present
limited by the blinders
of a small set of national
narratives.
And my friend John
Bowle,[phonetic] from the Center
for Muslim Christian
Understanding suggested
as I was finishing the book
that like the 18th
century revolutionaries
who ventured beyond borders.
In John's words, quote,
Muslim militants are working
to create nonnational
revolutionary narratives, and many
or our policy makers have
difficulty in understanding that.
Revolutionaries from out of
the way places who struggled
against unbeatable odds 200
years ago have much to say
to readers living in a world where
revolutions of all sizes had varied,
unpredicted and interconnected
outcomes.
I'm suggesting that we ignore
them at our peril, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Some questions, yes?
>> Have you as you're doing your
research for your various books,
do you find that you [inaudible]
that you're looking for
and so you go to an institution.
Possibly outside the country
or is it that you know
that certain institutions might
have interesting stuff and you go
to those institutions to
see what you might find?
>> Janet Polasky: Probably -- oh so
when I go to a different library,
do I go looking for
certain documents or do I go
because I know they might
be an interesting repository
that would house documents that
might prove of interest, is that?
And I would say it's
both, usually I'd go
because I know they have a certain
document, a certain set of letters.
I know from looking through catalogs
that they have a certain set
of pamphlets for example.
But while I'm there
I never stop at that.
I mean you always have
to give yourself time
to see what you will just upon by
serendipity as I did when I started
out by finding those
letters by Thomas Paine.
Not usually because I've
ordered the wrong folio
but you know you'll look through,
in the old days, you know looking
through the cards to
see what they have.
It's often by talking with
librarians and archivists to find
out what's there as well.
I was working on a biography
of a study of the finding
of social democracy at the end of
the 19th century and I was working
in the archives of the
socialist party in Belgium
and the archives is in Brussels.
And she said oh you might be
interested in these boxes,
you know we didn't have
any place to put them,
I mean and we all have
these stories, you know.
We didn't have any place to
put them and you're in luck
because they're in
the women's restroom.
And there they were you know,
there was this pile of boxes
and there was this whole
great set of correspondence
that no one had yet had time.
Or the funding to again, that's
a major issue, to catalog.
So, I think it's both but
that's a great question, thanks.
Yes, please.
>> It strikes me that at least
among the American revolutionaries,
which is a group that
I'm familiar with,
there were some definitely
identified
with the international
revolutionary impulse [inaudible]
where others very much did not.
And of course as you know Paine
in part because of his rejection
of traditional Christianity,
was close to being a pariah
by the time he came back to the U.S.
at the very beginning
of the 19th century.
>> Janet Polasky: Right and yeah
I think what's interesting too is
if you look at overtime.
I mean it's the 1790's where you
really find the sort of strident,
we aren't French, we're Americans
and you find that rhetoric,
the national rhetoric I think
that becomes distinguished
from everything else.
That's outside there
whether it's the Caribbean,
which is even more
frightening than France.
And I do tell my students
that if think political rhetoric is
charged now, they read the accounts
of Thomas Paine trying to
come back to American shores
when he wants to come back.
There are these great newspaper
accounts of Paine being caged
in France with the animals in a
zoo and being fed you know handouts
and -- yeah I mean Paine is,
well because he had taken
on George Washington saying --
Paine almost went to the guillotine.
And he appealed to George
Washington to help him get out.
Paine's cell mate Cloots did go to
the guillotine, Paine was too sick
so actually just barely escaped but
Washington wouldn't help him at all.
So he wrote an open letter
attacking George Washington.
So if you're faced with who do
we side with, George Washington,
Thomas Paine, guess who
won, George Washington.
And so then Thomas
Paine comes across --
yeah part of it is his religion and
part of it also is that he had dared
to take on national institutions
and he doesn't find the revolution
going the way he wants to.
So he ends up being denied
to vote which I think is one
of those really telling stories.
So yes, and I guess the
other answer to your question
about the nationalism is that as
these revolutions develop that's
where I do see the
nationalism come and so
to say there's cosmopolitanism is
not to say there's not nationalism.
I think it's -- I mean I think Cont
[phonetic] defines cosmopolitanism
in this period precisely
because it is a period
where nationalism has
its roots as well.
So that's an important point.
Other questions, yes?
>> Looking at documents in French
and English, did you [inaudible]
or primarily French and English?
>> Janet Polasky: Yeah, so what
languages were my documents in?
The ones I could read were in
French and English and Dutch
and Spanish and some German.
Some Latin actually, some
of the Belgium pamphlets.
When I got to Polish I ran into
trouble, but I happened to be
at a conference in Budapest where
they needed someone to represent --
it was for Central European, this
was years ago looking at roots
of liberal democracy
in western Europe.
Where arguing could nationalism and
liberalism work together and to find
that they went back and
looked at the 19th century.
But they couldn't find someone to
represent both halves of Belgium
so they ask me to do it,
which was really exciting.
That was great fun but so I
had colleagues that were there
that were native Polish speakers
and so I called on their skills.
But language is something that --
I mean that's one of those things
I keep telling my students you need
languages, John Bowle
has made a career
of telling our students
that as well.
That they really -- those
languages are absolutely essential,
so yeah I did have to read
in other languages as well.
But now it's going to be just as bad
with our students who
can't read cursive.
So I can't write comments on my
papers anymore I have to hand write,
I mean I have to print them.
And I think how are they going to
read, how are they going to come
down to manuscripts
and read the documents?
That will be a really
interesting issue, so yeah.
>> Was the handwriting by Americans,
I would like to think better
back then than it is today?
>> Janet Polasky: Yeah it's more
regular so that's absolutely true,
but you know obviously it's
different from one country
to another as well, from one culture
to another so you get used to it.
And you forget how hard
it is, I was just working
on a legal case actually
in my neighborhood
where we had some documents
from 1913 that had been written.
And I was so excited I scanned
them, I sent them off to the lawyer
and I said look I found the
documents that described the garden
that went with the house.
And he said well I can't
read these and I thought oh,
to me they were just as clear as
you know typing but they couldn't.
>> You obviously have [inaudible]
real educational niche opportunity
for somebody to teach a new language
called the way we used to write.
>> Janet Polasky: My Grandmother
would have taught that.
>> I must apologize, sort of missed
my question because I don't want
to take away from the subject
matter you specifically discussed
in your book which definitely
[inaudible] a copy of that,
it's a wonderful book, a
fascinating presentation.
But I was also struck during
it by the fact that it seems
like we might be living in
an age of international,
non-nation state based cultural
revolutionized [inaudible]
of the west.
Almost like Marks again or I mean
and the question I have
for you is [inaudible].
>> Janet Polasky: To John, yes.
>> Is where might one go to
be informed about the kinds
of interconnections and the kinds of
elements in thinking there are going
to have to be synthesized or
they're attempting to be synthesized
or not being very well
synthesized now in this era?
>> Janet Polasky: So where do
we go to understand a world
that crosses borders in this
particular age when we think
so much within national borders.
And we think that the way to
solve things is just fortify
national borders.
>> Somehow maybe there's some
answers, some useful pieces
of information, I'm wondering
what you're aware of in terms
of the work that's
being done in that?
>> Janet Polasky: Well, I will defer
to John on that because I think one
of those interesting things
about how do you go from history
to understanding our world is more
that what history teachers us is not
to expect what we expect.
And to always be prepared for
something completely different
and the fact that we do have learned
to understand the past
in our own way.
Does give us those skills I think
to understand what we see around us
but it's never what we've
seen before and John --
>> Would you like to
add to that please?
>> Yeah,[inaudible] in
terms of contemporary.
I think there is, to me there's an
18th century model that's slightly
different that comes out of
the scientific revolution.
And there was an old phrase
called the invisible college
which were people who
had interconnections
that Janet is talking about.
And now the difference is
that the informal gossip
and rumors stuff can now be
available on the internet.
But as I like to tell my graduate
students in particular I say
if your name is Aukmed
[phonetic] or Mohammad or something
like that don't spend too much
time on the internet looking
at the Islamic state website
because Homeland Security
might come and visit you.
But it's now it's scattered, the
difference is that there isn't
yet a full Library of Congress
collection that I can go
to for the contemporary
Islamic state stuff.
But the process is still the same.
>> Janet Polasky: Forever.
>> John Cole: All right
well thank you John
or thank you Janet in particular
[ Applause ]
You book is wonderful and you're
also a terrific speaker giving us
your enthusiasm and
also your knowledge.
And your own conclusions which are
also in the book but it was great
to hear you in person and
to have a chance to host you
at the Library of Congress.
I forgot two items that are
out there, we also would love
to have you fill out if you have
a chance after you buy the book
and are waiting for the autograph.
The event survey and we also
have a list of our future talks
that I see needed replenishing,
but I'll bring it back down
and for the signing [inaudible] time
when you're filling out the form.
But let's give Janet one more round
of applause for a wonderful book
and a wonderful performance.
>> Janet Polasky: Thank
you very much.
>> This has bene a been a
presentation of the library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.